Okay, wo habe ich meine flasche wasser hingeschmissen
Drum ist die sind so durchsichtig die sieht man teilweise nicht
random vor allem wenn sie hinter jeder menge miss steht
doch
Letztens hat mich doch jemand gefragt ob beim black friday was gescheites dabei gewesen ist
und ich habe gesagt ne wahrscheinlich nicht
also
Ne bis jetzt nicht aber ist wahrscheinlich auch nicht so
und
dementsprechend dachte ich mir wir gucken mal zusammen irgendwie
die üblichen verdächtigen an
Wenn ihr irgendwas gutes habt
Wenn ihr was gutes habt sagt bescheid es kommen gute kopfhörer am freitag exzellent was denn für welche
Was hast du dir denn geholt
Dass die geballt
Geschneid
Ich habe es falsch gelesen du hoffst es kommen gute kopfhörer ich
muss die nachrichten teilweise
teilweise mal lesen anstatt einfach nur so halbe sekunde drauf zu gucken
Ich habe ich habe ich habe rausgelesen du hast die kopfhörer bestellt die kommen hoffentlich bis freitag
Ja, das ist natürlich die frage ob da was das es gibt ja meistens ein paar gescheite sachen
Hey ohne scheiß
Mittlerweile ist das so bescheuert ja erst hatten wir black friday dann hatten wir cyber monday und black friday
Dann hatten wir black friday week und cyber monday week oder was auch immer und dann hatten wir irgendwann
black friday monat
Cyber monday monat ich warte noch dass irgendeiner sagt heute
2024 black friday ja
Also das ist wirklich komplett zumal ganz ehrlich bei den meisten sachen spaßt ja noch mal großartig was lässt sich hauptsächlich dazu verleiten
Zeug zu kaufen was du überhaupt nicht brauchst
und wenn es doch brauchst
Dann ist es oftmals gar nicht so billig wie es den anschein hat gerade bei amazon sieht es dann immer so geil aus 60 prozent billiger
Guckt man mal irgendwo anders ja okay es ist ein bisschen billiger aber wenn hat man irgendwie zehn euro gespart oder sowas also naja
Es gibt prime days ja es gibt da gibt es die haben doch
Dann haben so eine weihnachtssale und alles die haben die haben quasi ein drittel des jahres gefühlt ist da irgendein super
krasser sale der jetzt ganz ganz wichtig und bald ist er vorbei und jetzt musst du unbedingt kaufen
Und dann musst du in die gruppe kommen
Ohne ich muss das zu machen das kann das kann ich mir nicht geben dass ich muss ich muss schließen
Nicht nicht dass ich aus versehen hier noch
So ich wollte updates machen hatte ich habe ich schon ok reboot ja ich werde es ihr werdet es nicht glauben ich habe tatsächlich heute
ein bisschen auf stream daran weitergebaut
Und ich glaube nächsten stream können wir tatsächlich mal versuchen ich habe auch schon die ersten
Im front ist ja gar nichts drin ich habe auch schon tatsächlich die allerersten
Ich glaube ich hier schon drin habe
Ich habe schon angefangen
mit ffmpeg
Also noch nichts wirklich nur included bisher die webcams auszulesen dass da können wir das nächste mal weitermachen
So das kommt alles weg alles weg reboot
Ja er bei udemy ist es auch so heftig es ist es ist generell so wenn du mal guckst
Guck auch mal wir bauen heute gar nichts heute heute nicht heute nicht das heute noch mal rast
Dritten tag in folge rast das halte ich geistig da ist geistig dritte dritte durch
Also was was wir gebaut haben ist kann ich dir kurz sagen
beziehungsweise wo wir noch am bauen sind ist
Wir bauen eine
Web rtc also wir benutzen eine web rtc library in rust
um
in unserer asp.net core web anwendung
Webcams zu streamen in den browser sowas habe ich schon mal gemacht damals mit go und bisschen selbst gebastelt noch
Aber ich dachte mir wir machen das mal mit einer rast library da kann man ein bisschen rast lernen und ich sagte ja rast lernen war
glaube ich keiner als gute idee
das ist eine ganz
abartige sprache in manchen
Bereichen und sonderlich lesbar auch nicht welche kameras sind denn gerade gut weiß ich nicht
Ich habe also ich kann nicht sagen welche ich habe ich habe
zwei
weiß cams
mit custom firmware
Eine im flur eine an der heizung und im keller dass ich die
Thermostate und druckanzeige ablesen kann
Und dann habe ich reolink china chinesen dinger weil die ohne cloud funktionieren und per rtsp einfach abgerufen werden können
aber ansonsten
Black friday jahrzehnt ja
Was wollte ich denn jetzt eben sagen
Ja, ihr müsst mal gucken es hat ja alle laufend irgendwas es ist genauso alle internet anbieter also alle provider haben ja gefühlt auch
das ganze jahr über
Irgendeine super krasse sonderaktion die läuft jetzt nur noch eine woche oder läuft einen monat jetzt läuft sie nur noch eine woche
Und dann wurde es weil es so beliebt war eine woche verlängert und es war so beliebt dass wir noch mal einen monat oben drauf
Die sind es sind so richtige gönner immer alle und sobald das vorbei ist kostet auch nicht mehr als die nächste aktion am start
also im prinzip ist es dauert sie bäht
und
Es zieht halt es zieht und deswegen waren das alle ich finde es auch nicht verwerflich ist schon okay
Aber ich finde es immer lächerlich wenn sie so tun als gibt es das alles nur einmal im jahr was die haben eine klingel
ich mal gucken
das ding da
Moment das ist doch diese stadt ey das ist doch diese standard china chinesen
Türklingel die es unter fünf verschiedenen brands gibt die gleiche habe ich auch hier
Allerdings von irgendeinem anderen hersteller nicht reolink ja ja ja die genauso
shelly da können wir mal gucken
Was was shelly am start ist eine gute idee da kommt man mal kurz rein
Ja als poe ist sehr sehr praktisch aber bei mir ist das problem ich kriege poe nicht so ohne weiteres durch die wand
Nee das nicht der nachfolger von ring
Ich weiß nicht ob es ring noch gibt aber sowas wäre mir nie in die ins haus gekommen
shelly bis zum 27 november leute soll ich euch mal was erzählen was
Extremly pork ist
Für solche momente war der mark
Die mode ich brauche brauche kürzest pocky mode pock pock pock
safe image
Download we get
Hallo
Copy image link wie geht und jetzt wollte ich sagen image cat
pock
das brauche ich weil also wenn wir wenn wir pock nicht offen
Im terminal haben dann weiß ich auch nicht so jetzt habe ich natürlich vor lauter pock downloaden und das schöne ist wenn man
Wenn man pock im terminal hat kann man auch noch eine schleife drum machen
und dann hat man
Unendliche pocks
Das ist quasi vertikel pock slide
Richtiges pocking das problem ist ich habe jetzt ganz vergessen warum ich eigentlich
pock runterladen wollte
Hauptsache hauptsache wir haben massive massive pock ausgabe im terminal
Ja aber ach so ja ich wollte euch was erzählen was extremly pock ist jetzt weiß ich wieder und zwar guckt mal hier
Wenn wir uns den aktuellen kalender so angucken da stellen wir fest
Dass wir in der vorletzten november woche sind was sagt euch das chat
Das rein rhetorische frage ihr könnt das nicht wissen das sagt uns
dass ich nur noch
Dass ich nur noch morgen
Übermorgen also im prinzip dass ich nur noch vier tage arbeiten gehen muss
Morgen ist den ganzen tag wieder super agiles hyper agile gemiete da mache ich nichts aber das ist ja so gewollt
Und dann habe ich noch drei tage wo ich wirklich arbeiten muss und dann
Habe ich für
November für die letzte wobei das stimmt nicht so ganz hier muss ich hier müsste ich hier müsste ich theoret
Hier müsste ich theoretisch auch noch arbeiten aber da haben wir so eine komische veranstaltung
zwei tage lang
Die ist nicht in frankfurt die die ist hier in der nähe woanders
Und
Da fahre ich hin das ist auch quasi meine letzte amtshandlung dann dieses jahr
Und dann ist urlaub stellt dann ist quasi von hier
bis kompletten dezember bis ersten arbeitstag im januar
der nicht montag ist
Moment leckt es wieder ein bisschen
habe ich quasi
über einen monat
bei
Dass beim arbeitgeber wechsel keinen resturlaub nehmen müssen nein muss ich nicht
Der neue arbeitgeber hat gesagt sie übernehmen das wenn ich ihnen eine bescheinigung bringe wie viel ich schon genommen habe
Da muss ich auch noch bei der personalabteilung anrufen weil die haben irgendwas nicht richtig gebucht
Aber die haben gesagt sie machen das und das ist sehr sehr nice das heißt ich brauche jetzt 17 tage für
das restliche jahr und dann habe ich noch mal
ja irgendwie
Vier oder fünf tage übrig den kann ich da noch anfangen nächsten jahres oder so so sieht es aus
Hocke ja finde ich das gut
Da wollen wir noch mal schauen ob schelli irgendwas gescheites am start hat
Ach ja hat hat my deals oder so wieder so eine übersicht für black friday
Die haben noch meistens eine ganz brauchbare übersicht immer hier black friday dient
Das ganze machen wir allerdings mal auf dort wo ich den dark theme am start habe
Und dark reader am start habe gleich viel besser
Wir können es auch einfach wir können es auch einfach in der vm aufmachen dann hat es wenigstens einen sinn dass die vm an ist
kennst du nein
So gucken wir gleich rein das ist mal kurz checken was schelli schelli hat bei schelli ist das
Ist auch nicht alles doll
Aber gerade diese unterputz
Relais die finde ich ganz nice da habe ich auch ein paar im einsatz wobei ich viel mehr
Noch verbauen wollte seit jahren schon und habe es nie gemacht ich traue mich da auch nicht richtig ran
top angebote
Smartes sicherheits bundle
Schelli gateway schelli ja super krass high security das ist doch auch irgendein bild aus
Was die ei generiert hat hier oder
Vielleicht zugrande
Scherley smoke juckt mich scherles magist will ich nicht die halten angeblich nicht lange habe ich irgendwo meinem review gelesen
ja weil
lange batterie lebensdauer so so
Fünf jahre mit wifi connection da habe ich schon meine zweifel ob das stimmt
Da brauche ich nicht also die steckdosen die finde ich die taugen nix die haben gar keine großen features das nur eine steckdose
Kein usb und sonst was das gefällt mir nicht
Ich persönlich mag ja auch wenn die noch einen schalter haben wobei die haben vielleicht schalter dass man einen ausschalten kann ohne rein rauszustecken
Mit was laufen die schelles mit wifi oder sick beat mit wifi shelley dimmer prominent shelley blumen
Warten
Ist es ein wifi button oder bl e button okay sowas ist tatsächlich
ganz praktisch
Je nachdem was man dafür anwendungszweck geführt aber so ein bl e button kann man ganz gut verwenden
Für alle möglichen dinger wenn man halt einfach mal irgendwas was braucht haben wir so irgendwie
an der tür
hinhängen zum draufdrücken und sowas und dann beispielsweise
checken lassen ob alle fenster zu sind oder
Mit dem button irgendwie das wohnzimmer in
Wir wollen jetzt film gucken versetzen oder was auch immer gibt es gibt es gibt es sich varianten
wobei
Also das ist aber gut dass es auf bl e basiert bl eher das ist also quasi low energy bluetooth das verbraucht nicht so viel strom
Ich habe ich habe mir vor einer weile mal so ein sick be
akara
Xiaomi china chinesen multi button ding gekauft mit insgesamt sechs buttons drauf die man dann alle auch noch unterschiedlich
Ansteuern kann also du kannst single klick machen doppel klick triple klick und lang klick also hast du theoretisch
Massig möglichkeiten sachen zu schalten und eigentlich benutze ich das nur im ersten stock um licht an und aus zu machen aber ist ganz praktisch
Du hast io broker am start
Was hatte ich denn muss ich mal fragen weil ich habe mit io broker auch schon so ein bisschen rum gebastelt aber habe jetzt bisher
noch nicht so den für mich den den überzeugenden punkt gefunden versus home assistant ich habe
Io blocker hauptsächlich in eins im einsatz weil es dafür eins zwei coole plugins gibt die ich so noch nicht für home assistant gefunden habe
aber
Wenn ich wenn ich ausschalten würde wird es mich auch nicht so sehr so sehr stören
Warum ist es bei dir home assistant nicht warum warum ist es bei dir io broker
Was gefällt dir da dran
Ich will jetzt keinem sagen was er nehmen soll es interessiert mich nur einfach gibt es eigentlich so p o e all in one
wlan ap raumsensor rauchmeldung
Keine ahnung also p o e wlan access point gibt es aber ob es ein
Wlan access point mit raumsensor und rauchmelder und bewegungsmelder gibt
Das wäre cool
Und ich könnte mir durchaus vorstellen dass es sowas im businessbereich auch gibt
Auf der anderen seite sind die geräte vielleicht schlecht schlecht zu integrieren
Wobei wobei ich jetzt nicht wüsste was dagegen sprechen sollte
Ja das das ist das ist nice aber warum ist jetzt die wahl auf io broker gefallen ich meine das könnte theoretisch mit jedem mit
Jeder home assistant nicht wieder smart home lösung machen war das einfach das erst beste
Ich meine man muss nämlich sagen io blocker ist gerade in deutschland ziemlich beliebt
Ich würde einfach interessieren was
Was den leuten daran gefällt und warum sie es benutzt ja das stimmt schon aber das wäre ein schlechter
Hat jemand einen lichtsensor im einsatz würde gern checker im keller das licht brennen wird oft vergessen
Ja
habe ich habe ich was selbst gebaut ist aber kein kein lichtsensor der als lichtsensor verkauft wird sondern
ich erkenne
Blinken der leds und solche geschichten das ist aber das aber auch ein lichtsensor und das ist ganz super easy gelöst und zwar ist es ein
20er pack
rotoresistor
Ja hier zwar hier keine ahnung zwanzig zehn zehner pack 350
Und dann an einem esp 82 66 dran du kannst ja auch so ein fertiges board kaufen
dann hast du direkten da hast du meistens noch so einen
Genau sowas hier sowas hier ist auch nicht verkehrt da hast du noch so einen wie nennt sich das dinger
Potentiometer oder sowas so den wurde die empfindlichkeit einstellen kannst ab wann es den digitalen output gibt
Also sowas kannst du auch nehmen und und dann an jeden x beliebigen microcontroller da siehst du ob es lichtern ist das ist easy es
Kostet kostet kostet wenn du wenn du bock hast sowas selbst zu bauen
kannst du zehn stück bauen für
20 euro oder so
Gibt es aber auch garantiert schon fertig 100 pro
Ja
Ich habe sowas gebaut zum leds auslesen
Aber wenn die leds auslesen können können die auch lichter der decke auslesen
Aber das ist natürlich nur für bastler diese die selbst bauen wollen ansonsten 100 pro gibt es auch fertige sachen
Das ziel ist eine web rtc anwendung zu bauen der nicht so wirklich
Nicht so wirklich das ist noch von gestern drinne
Wichtig ist dass es funktioniert und alles unterstützt was man eben an hardware hat
Aura to snogs dankeschön für den sub das ist
exzellent
So also was haben sonst noch bei shelly also den button den könnte man benutzen wenn man sonst noch nix hat
Wie das war es schon an ihr unten geht es noch weiter
Was sind das für welche die sind noch mal extra klein oder wie
Da ist die stelle seite backt rum was haben die denn was was ist also die sind die sind viereckig oder so in die richtung im vergleich zu den
Originalen shellys die glaube ich ein bisschen rundlicher waren wenn ich das noch richtig im kopf hab ja ja so oder so
Ja, also ich glaube die sind noch mal extra klein
Originalen shellys die glaube ich ein bisschen rundlicher waren wenn ich das noch richtig im kopf hab ja ja so
Oder was heißt rundherr so wobei waren die originalen shellys nicht sogar noch ein bisschen rundlicher
Ich habe hier irgendwo in der box welche liegen noch
Morgen wieder rast war mal gucken ich habe heute aber noch ein bisschen weiter gemacht auf github gepusht morgen kann man ein video drüber übertragen
Okay, die sind einfach ein bisschen kleiner
Input
Geht nicht mehr mit 12 volt anscheinend
Nee es geht es geht doch doch geht geht
Es geht bis bis
Bis 30 volt dc das ist ganz gut dass man damit auch was anderes schalten kann als nur was aus der steckdose kommt das finde ich sehr praktisch
Wichtig ist ja dabei beim shelly auch dass er eben damit betrieben werden kann
So, ansonsten sind die einfach nur kleiner und der Rest ist glaube ich gleich.
Okay, wenn man es braucht ist es nicht verkehrt.
Aber das ist mir viel zu teuer.
Hauptsache er ist auf der Hutschiene drauf.
Ansonsten gibt es glaube ich nichts spannendes mehr.
Shelly Uni, da habe ich auch einen hier.
Den finde ich enorm praktisch, aber den habe ich dann doch nicht verwendet.
Den finde ich enorm praktisch, weil er eben schon klein ist.
Und sich auch hier mit jedem x-beliebigen Netzteil und quasi jedem Gerät anschließen lässt.
Und er ist sogar verhältnismäßig preislich echt in Ordnung.
Darf man in einer Mietwohnung einfach Shellys in die Wand schrauben?
Ganz ehrlich, vermutlich schon.
Solange du nichts kaputt machst und sie im Zweifelsfall wieder entfernst, wenn du raus gehst.
Weil es ist ja wieder reversibel quasi mit Shellys.
Vermutlich wird es schlicht und ergreifend gar keiner merken.
Die Frage ist, ob du an der Elektroinstallation rumwurschteln solltest, wenn du keine Ahnung davon hast.
Ist Shelly ein Closed Ökosystem?
Nein, glücklicherweise nicht.
Das ist auch der Grund, warum Shellys eines der Sachen sind, die ich immer empfehle.
Wenn einer Probleme hat, die man damit lösen kann.
Und ich selbst auch welche im Einsatz habe.
Shelly selbst, also es gibt die verschiedensten Möglichkeiten.
Wenn du gar keinen Bock auf die Shelly-Firmware hast, dann kannst du das Motor drauf installieren.
Musst du aber nicht, würde ich mittlerweile auch nicht mehr machen.
Die Shelly-Firmware ist wirklich gut.
Das Gute ist, Shellys lassen sich in Home Assistant und so gut wie jedes Smart Home System integrieren.
Und das brauchst du nicht.
Ich glaube sogar, dass Shellys mittlerweile MQTT können.
Da bin ich mir aber nicht ganz sicher.
Das wurde mal angeteasert vor einer Weile.
Und eine Web-IP haben sie auch.
Also die sind wirklich nicht schlecht, die Dinger.
Kann ich LEDs direkt abschließen?
Was?
Blicke ich schnell durch.
Also die Shelly-Sachen, das ist kein Smart Home Hub System, wie man sich das vorstellt.
Das sind Geräte, die man in ein bestehendes Smart Home System integrieren kann.
Du kannst die Dinger auch Standalone mit der App verwenden.
Das funktioniert auch gut, wenn du nicht so viele Geräte hast.
Also was du mit dem Shelly machen kannst, ist zum Beispiel.
Nehmen wir mal das Ding, was wir eben hatten hier.
Den Klassiker.
Nimm das Ding mal hier.
Was du damit machen kannst, ist folgendes.
Man sieht es ja hier auch.
Du kannst die beispielsweise in die Dose machen, wo dein Lichtschalter dran ist.
Und dann schaltest du mit dem Lichtschalter nicht mehr direkt das Licht an der Decke.
Sondern du schaltest mit dem Lichtschalter den Shelly.
Und der Shelly schaltet dann das Licht an der Decke.
Da denkt man sich jetzt erstmal so.
Wo ist denn da jetzt der Sinn von, wenn ich da ein Gerät dazwischen habe.
Und mit dem Schalter nach wie vor schalten kann.
Das Ding ist.
Du kannst dann nicht nur mit dem Schalter schalten.
Nein.
Du kannst dann auch über dein Smart Home schalten.
Und dein Schalter an der Wand funktioniert nach wie vor.
Das ist ja aus meiner Sicht eines der Fehler.
Den Leute machen, die anfangen mit Smart Home.
Die sagen dann.
Oh ja.
Das erste was ich mache ist smarte Beleuchtung.
Und das nächste was sie machen ist.
Wenn sie aus dem Raum raus gehen.
Drücken sie an den Schalter an der Tür.
Und dann war es das mit smarter Beleuchtung.
Weil smarte Beleuchtung ist nur so lang smart.
Wie sie Strom hat.
Also logisch.
Und deswegen ist es oftmals viel sinnvoller.
Weiter den Schalter an der Wand zu verwenden.
Und eine stinknormale Glühbirne.
Oder halt.
Welche Lampe.
Welches Leuchtmittel.
Wie man heutzutage so schön sagt.
Je sonste verwendet.
Und du kannst damit theoretisch auch das Licht dimmen.
Da brauchst du aber einen anderen Shelly.
Gibt es auch Dimmer.
Und da kannst du nach wie vor mit dem Schalter an der Wand schalten.
Ja.
Also gerade für die Frau.
Oder die Mutter.
Oder die Oma.
Ist das gut.
Habe ich so.
Öfters jetzt zumindest schon.
Gelesen.
Dass das gerne.
Ja.
Dass die Mädels da nicht so technikaffin sind.
Sagen wir es mal so.
Und dass sie halt gerne einen Knopf wollen.
Anstatt sein Handy zum bedienen.
Ist bei mir hier nicht anders.
Ja.
Und deswegen finde ich das gut.
Wenn die Buttons weiter noch funktionieren.
An der Wand.
Und man zusätzlich an der Decke schalten kann.
So.
Und.
Was man natürlich dann auch noch machen kann ist.
Wenn man jetzt an der Decke.
Dann nicht eine normale Lampe hat.
Sondern wirklich eine smarte Lampe.
Mit LEDs.
RGB Beleuchtung.
Dass man die Farbe ändern kann.
Den Ton vom Licht.
Beziehungsweise auch die Helligkeit.
Dann kann man das nämlich so einschalten.
Dass der Shelly gar nicht mehr wirklich den Strom ein- und ausschaltet.
An der Decke.
Sondern dass der Shelly quasi nur noch dieses Lichtschalter.
Wurde gedrückt.
Weiter reicht.
An dein Smart Home Hub.
Und der dann quasi über Wifi die Lampe ein- und ausschaltet.
Aber es geht nach wie vor mit dem Lichtschalter an der Wand.
Und das ist sehr praktisch.
Also da sind dann quasi der Freiheit keine Grenzen gesetzt.
Was man machen kann.
Ja.
Richtig.
Und.
Das nächste ist.
Vielleicht braucht ihr gar keine smarten RGB LED Lampen.
Weil die meisten Leute wollen ja gar nichts mit den Lampen großartig machen.
Die wollen die Lampen über die App einen ausschalten können.
Oder übers Handy einen ausschalten können.
So nach dem Motto.
Ah ich sitze gerade vor dem Fernseher.
Habe in der Küche das Licht angelassen.
Ich will es von da aus schalten können.
Kannst du mit so einem Shelly ganz ohne Probleme machen.
Kannst einfach die klassische Lampe drin lassen.
Und.
Der nächste Step.
Was die Leute wollen ist.
Dimmbare Lampen.
Der nächste Step den die Leute wollen ist.
Dimmbar und Farbton.
Und nur ganz wenige Leute wollen wirklich RGB.
Das ist ja auch so ein Ding.
Das habe ich schon hundert mal gesagt.
Wenn ich das dann auch teilweise auf Reddit oder in irgendwelchen Foren sehe.
Oder auch hier teilweise im Stream.
Wenn die Leute anfangen.
Hier ich mache mir jetzt überall RGB hin.
Die meisten Stellen im Haus brauchen kein RGB.
Die brauchen Remote ein- und ausschaltbar.
Die brauchen vielleicht Dimmbar.
Die brauchen vielleicht Farbton.
Also weiß.
Wie heißt das.
Temperatur.
Einstellmöglichkeiten.
Aber die brauchen kein komplettes RGB.
Komplettes RGB ist meistens ultra teuer.
Und du benutzt es eh nicht.
An manchen Stellen macht es Sinn.
Dort wo es Sinn macht kann man es machen.
Bei den meisten anderen Lampen voll und ganz so gut wie es ist.
Genau.
Doch.
Heute ist Black Friday Week.
Black Friday Monat.
Black Friday Jahr.
Was auch immer.
Möchtest du eine E-Tonne USV 860 Watt für ein Synology NAS verwenden.
Bei uns fällt bei Spannungsspitzen öfters mal der Strom aus.
Ja und nein.
Du musst gucken bei USVs was es für USV Typen sind.
Und was der Hersteller bzw. ob du dazu was findest.
Ob die USV.
Ich hab es vergessen wie es heißt.
Ob die.
Wie hieß denn das.
Ja genau.
Ob die Hot Swap fähig ist.
Das musst du gucken.
Weil.
Der Trick ist.
Eigentlich interessiert dich Hot Swap Fähigkeit nur am Rande.
Was dich allerdings interessiert bei USVs.
Und was die Hersteller oftmals nicht so hinschreiben ist.
Ob die USV weiter funktioniert wenn die Batterie kaputt ist.
Und ja der reinen Lehre nach hast du sowas wie Online USVs.
Online Interactive USVs.
Bei Online USVs geht es immer durch die Batterie.
Wenn die Batterie kaputt ist.
Dann.
Geht die Stromversorgung nicht mehr.
Obwohl.
Obwohl es quasi noch.
Gar nicht ausgefallen ist.
Aber selbst.
Aber das sind die meisten.
Bisschen günstigere nicht.
Aber.
Es gibt beispielsweise.
Normale so relativ günstige USVs.
Die schalten um.
Wenn der Strom ausfällt.
Auf die Batterie.
Aber.
Wenn die Batterie kaputt ist.
Und der Strom noch weiter geht.
Dann gehen sie einfach aus.
So nach dem Motto.
Ja ich verstehe den Sinn auch nicht.
Cyberpower ist so ein Kandidat.
Ja.
Cyberpower.
Schaltet.
Zumindest die die ich mal hier im Einsatz hatte.
Cyberpower.
Schaltet die Stromversorgung aus.
Wenn die Batterie kaputt ist.
Es ist keine Online USV.
Ist komplett sinnlos.
Deswegen hab.
Deswegen.
Der Trick um rauszukriegen.
Ob deine USV abkackt.
Wenn die Batterie abkackt.
Ist.
Guck ob du eine USV.
Kannst.
Wir können.
Wir können ja mal gucken.
Welche willst du denn.
Sag mir mal welche du willst.
Da gucken wir mal nach.
Ob wir dazu was finden.
Der Trick ist.
Nachzugucken.
Ob die USV.
Hotswap.
Fähig ist.
Wenn die USV.
Hotswap.
Fähig ist.
Also mit Hotswap.
Fähig ist gemeint.
Du kannst die Batterie.
Im laufenden Betrieb.
Rausziehen.
Und eine neue rein machen.
Wenn die Hotswap.
Fähig ist.
Dann muss die auch.
Einen Batterie Ausfall.
Verkraften.
Hotswap.
Also ich.
Ich habe auch eine von APC.
Ich habe eine.
Und ich.
Ich war.
Ich war eine Zeit lang.
Gar nicht so der große APC.
Bin ich immer noch nicht.
Die Dinger stinken wie Sau.
Und wirken irgendwie billig.
Aber die funktionieren.
Also die.
Die von APC.
Ich habe mir auch.
Eine ganz günstige.
Gekauft.
Als Ersatz.
Für.
Für meinen.
Für meine Cyberpower.
Also ich habe.
Eine.
Ja geil.
Doch.
Hier.
Geil.
Doch.
Hier.
Hier stand es doch.
Ich habe.
Eine.
Moment.
APC.
56.
V.A.
M.I.
B.R.
Ne.
Steht da nix.
Ich glaube.
Die hier.
Ich bin mir unschlüssig.
Ob es wirklich die.
Die sieht ja auf jeden Fall.
Sehr ähnlich.
Ja.
Wenn man gewarnt wird.
Wenn die Batterie kaputt ist.
Das finde ich ja in Ordnung.
Ja.
Aber sie sollte nicht ausfallen.
Ich habe ein paar Jahre.
In meinem Rack hier.
Hatte es.
Als die Batterie.
Von der USV.
Kaputt gegangen ist.
Nicht der Stromausfall.
Also.
So ein.
So ein Ding.
Aber ich habe.
Ich am Start.
Ich finde die.
Ganz okay.
Wichtig.
Bei USVs.
Auch immer.
Dass sie die Möglichkeit haben.
Die.
Die Bilderauflösung.
Ist halt voll pp.
Gar.
Dass sie die Möglichkeit haben.
Hier USB.
Anzuschließen.
Ich habe.
Sinnlos.
Gelabert.
So ein.